jan ele wir wollen jetzt direkt schalten
nach münchen zu csu chef markus söder
und einer der aspiranten um die
kanzlerkandidatur bei der union
herr söder gestern hier im studio bei
bild da war armin laschet siegessicher
und heute morgen in dem präsidium der
cdu
da gab es dann auch nur unterstützende
stimmen so haben wir es zumindest gehört
wie haben sie das heute morgen
wahrgenommen wo waren sie und ja wir
haben sie die debatte verfolgt was da
bei der cdu passiert ist ja ich habe das
ergebnis gehört und einige stimmungen
aus der sitzung selber
das ist natürlich ein wichtiger beitrag
heute um zur weiter- und meinungsbildung
aber es kann nicht der einzige sein denn
er stellt er fest dass ein
parteivorstand präsidium wichtig ist
aber es ist ein sehr kleiner kreis ein
überschaubarer kreis und es ist wichtig
jetzt die nächsten tage hinein zu
horchen in partei und fraktion seit er
im laufe des tages das habe ich bei
ihnen allen gelesen auf bild live auch
andere stellungnahmen aus der cdu
gegeben
überraschung und enttäuschung und andere
meinungen also ich glaube ich sie mir
jetzt klug beraten wenn wir am ende da
einen gesamtprozess machen dann zu einem
ergebnis kommen
denn eines ist ganz entscheidend es
kommt nicht nur darauf an dass wir
jemand für gut finden sondern
entscheidend ist was die wähler und
wähler dazu sagen
denn am ende sehr klar die union steht
einer ganz schwierigen weggabelung muss
man sagen wenn man die umfragen ansieht
dann stehen wir nicht gut wir stehen wie
sie denn so schlecht vor einer
bundestagswahl seit 1998 stammt mir
nicht mehr so schlecht und da das jetzt
zu drehen und zu zeigen dass wir führen
wollen und führen können
das hängt sehr davon ab ob nicht nur
geschlossenheit erzeugen so noch
akzeptanz bei den menschen finden
sozusagen kanzlerkandidat werden sollten
und sie sagen ja weiterhin sie wollen
das dann bräuchten sie ja auch
unterstützung aus der cdu
da gab es jetzt heute nur ein
landesverband der sich für sie
ausgesprochen hat der berliner
landesverband waren sie da enttäuscht
nein überhaupt nicht ich meine man muss
ja wissen die parteien stattfinden ist
doch selbstverständlich dass seine
partei im parteipräsidium zunächst mal
vater kein beschluss gefasst aber auch
rückendeckung gibt für den eigenen
vorsitzenden
ich selber bin mit armin laschet
befreundet das kann man sagen ist in die
ganze zeit in dieser schwierigen phase
und einem sehr offenen
freundschaftlichen
miteinander gespräch und wir haben uns
auch am wochenende ausgetauscht haben
die möglichkeiten chancen aber auch die
risiken gemeinsam gewogen und wütendes
beide für sinnvoll dass wir beide auch
bereit sein müssen diese verantwortung
zu schultern
aber nicht nur aus formalen gründen weil
ich jetzt vorsitzender bin erst
vorsitzender sondern weil es am ende
darum geht wie sie die besten chancen
denn auch das muss doch klar sein wer
gewinnen will der muss sich daran
orientieren
wer und in welcher formation auch mit
welchen programmen die besten chancen
sind und da gibt es sehr viele menschen
in deutschland da gibt es nicht nur in
der csu sind in der cdu aber auch in
breiten teilen der bevölkerung auch den
wunsch und die bitte auch an mich
herangetragen dass ich mich zur
verfügung stellen möge das war auch der
grund übrigens warum ich dazu bereit bin
aber klar ist auch es wird hier kein auf
biegen und brechen geben
es wird auch kein kampf geben wie es
zwischen strauss & coll der fall war
oder auch mal wenn ich das sagen darf
zwischen merkel und seehofer
sondern werden ende ein gutes ergebnis
bekommen und hoffentlich das was die
menschen danach auch echt motiviert und
die mitglieder begeistert dann erklären
sie uns jetzt mal herr söder wie soll
das funktionieren die nächsten tage
werden sie persönlich in die fraktion
gehen werden sie mit den abgeordneten
von cdu/csu sprechen in den nächsten
tagen also die abgeordneten sollten sich
zunächst mal selbstständig ein bild
machen ob wir morgen in der fraktion
dabei sind oder nicht hängt auch ein
bisschen von der fraktion selber opfer
werden wie die persönliche bereit wären
gut beraten werden sie bei reichlich
natürlich habe ich ja schon gesagt wenn
der wunsch besteht bin ich gar nicht da
ich war ja auch am sonntag da beim
fraktionsvorstand das war für mich
übrigens der rahmen in dem es angemessen
war
diese frage zu verkünden nicht über die
medien oder nicht in einer partei green
um sondern bei denen die auch wahlkampf
machen müssen denn eins ist doch ganz
entscheiden die nächsten tage parteien
spekulieren ein bisschen prozent mehr
prozent weniger für viele abgeordnete
bedeutet ist aber nicht nur ein prozent
sondern möglicherweise der gewinn oder
verlust des wahlkreises wenn man auch
die entsprechenden umfragedaten schaut
wahlkreis de oder elektrischen oder was
es da alles so gibt dann sieht man das
früher sichere schwarze wahlkreise
plötzlich grün im süden roth im westen
und sehr viel blau im osten haben
insofern ist es schon eine ernste
weichenstellung
die das darf ich sagen möglicherweise
von der konstellation neuer koalitionen
länger geht als nur für jahre da muss
man sehr aufpassen und sehr abwägen was
man tut sie sprechen die
bundestagsfraktion anzusprechen auch
immer wieder die basis an gehen sie
davon aus dass die cdu-basis einen
kanzlerkandidaten söder favorisiert wenn
man die umfragen zusammen nimmt und auch
nach bei cdu-mitgliedern fragt dann gibt
es ein zumindest im interessantes bild
man muss nicht immer auf alle umfragen
gehören insbesondere nicht auf jede
einzelne aber wenn es einen gesamttrend
gibt dann ist es zumindest wichtig den
zu akzeptieren und ihn nicht zu
ignorieren und wir haben uns ja heute
auch gesagt okay das ist zu kurz eine
mitgliederbefragung zu machen
ich glaube wenn es eine
mitgliederbefragung geben stimmt warum
sagen wir sind in kürze ja sagen wir
weil wir in der kürze der zeit in der
die erwartungshaltung gibt es auch ist
das wahrscheinlich schlecht organisieren
können das sind glaube ich wird es das
würde jetzt uns soziales parteien
überfordern
ein solches verfahren ich glaube wir
können jetzt auch so hinbekommen
mir geht es ja nicht um die persönliche
ambition ich bin ja als minister weise
den bayern gut ausgelastet und als csu
vorsitzender aktiv beteiligt an einem
bundespolitischen entscheidungen geht es
jetzt nicht darum irgend ein
karriereziel zu finden
es war nicht meine lebensplanung aber
die erwartungshaltung und der wunsch der
menschen ist schon da und allein von
gestern auf heute ging bei uns unzählige
auch motivierende worte ein und auch
eine richtige aufbruchstimmung und das
waren wir sicher am ende auch für armin
erzeugen können wenn es denn zum
gemeinschaftlichen ergebnis kommt aber
das sollten wir in ruhe bedenken sorgsam
wegen oder ein bisschen zeit haben denn
eines möchte ich schon sagen es ist
wichtig dass die führungsgremien wir
sagen wenn wolfgang schäuble was sagt
mit seiner jahrzehntelangen ich glaube
40 50 jährigen erfahrung ist es wichtig
aber damals nicht wie volker bouffier
sich zu äußern und aber es ist auch
wichtig dass man in der breite der
mitglieder aber wie wird er sich wer
also der kleinen sich da von diesen
granden sozusagen wolfgang schäuble die
er viel erfahrung haben friedrich merz
der gegenkandidat von armin laschet war
dass da am ende heute niemand gesagt hat
mensch schaut auf die umfragen markus
söder muss machen
anscheinend hat das argument umfragen
keiner für wichtig empfunden
friedrich merz zum beispiel den ich sehr
schätze hat immer für sich in anspruch
genommen
bei seiner kandidatur dass er in
umfragen eine größere akzeptanz findet
jetzt hat er gesagt spielt vielleicht
keine rolle
ich bin da jedes argument total ernst
und und jetzt muss auch jeder selber
entscheiden
am ende müssen wir halt ein ergebnis
finden ein ergebnis das jetzt aber nicht
nur die kranken glücklich macht sondern
am ende auch beim wähler akzeptanz
findet wenn es dann zu sein soll dann
will ich das auch akzeptieren
aber ich hoffe schon normal dass wir
einfach noch mal drüber nachdenkt und
was uns erreicht es ist nicht nur ein
landesverband es gibt sehr viele stimmen
aus niedersachsen aus thüringen aus
rheinland pfalz von abgeordneten das
baden württemberg und anderen
bundesländern
da gibt es schon eine menge an
diskussionsstoff und haben das muss man
halt jetzt alles mal synchron schalten
wir werden sehen was rauskommt am ende
kommt sicher zum guten ergebnis
wenn sie jetzt die umfragen ansprechen
dann mal butter bei die fische herr
söder würden sie wenn sie jetzt antreten
würden für die union über 30 prozent
holen
also wenn der anspruch der union wäre
unter 30% zu bleiben werde als
selbstaufgabe der union also unser ziel
muss schon sein
ein deutlich besseres ergebnis 30
prozent zu ziehen also ganz einfachen
grund
wer unter 30 ist kam kaum und
führungsanspruch in der deutschen
politik definieren wir haben ein
potential es ist bei 35 plus ex national
ob das ganz ausgeschöpft wird hängt von
vielen faktoren ab das hängt davon ab
für unser programm sich gestaltet vor
allem wie die nächsten wochen im corolla
management laufen und das belastet ja
wir haben es in der ankündigung für
weitere beiträge gesehen
die menschen immens und stress die leute
holen hat armin laschet würden sie mehr
prozent erholen sind sie davon überzeugt
als amina das kann ich so nicht sagen
und es wäre jetzt auch unfair das zu
sagen das müssen ja die menschen
entscheiden
die spannende frage ist immer zehn
parteien personen oder zehn personen die
parteien in ihren
sie müssen zumindest nach den letzten
wahlen in umfragen gibt es ein
vielleicht indiz dass personen eine
wichtige rolle spielen können
das programm der cdu baden württemberg
war ein sensationelles programm
da war alles drin was das herz der union
begehrt es fand aber beim wähler nicht
ganz so den anlass also das muss man
dann am ende abwägen das werden wir dann
auch tun
und wenn es dann eine
mehrheitsentscheidung gibt da bin ich
wirklich leidenschaftlicher demokrat
dann akzeptiere ich das sagen aber ich
hab immer noch nicht so ganz verstanden
wie es jetzt weiter geht also sie sind
bereit in die fraktion zu gehen
vielleicht telefonieren sie dann noch
mal mit armin laschet darüber aber wo
genau findet denn dann diese
entscheidung statt sie haben müssen
abwarten wir müssen schauen wie die
basis reagiert wann ist denn der
zeitpunkt der tag der ort wo sie sagen
okay hier und heute wird entschieden nun
ein bayerischer lebenskünstler der mann
gesagt schauen wir mal dann sehen wir
schon
ich denke dass wir aber in dieser woche
zum ergebnis kommen können aber auch
nicht in einem hinterzimmer gespräch
sondern schon unter beteiligung einer
aus cdu/csu auch vielleicht in einem
gemeinsamen gespräch in dem wir das dann
führen können aber ich finde es muss
jetzt die entscheidung des heutigen
tages müssen sie kann und dann sehen wir
ob sie versichern oder daraus fruchtbare
neue ideen entstehen und dann mal
schauen was daraus folgt und wie gesagt
wir sind sehr offen
wir sind sehr offen für das gespräch und
wir waren am ende eine gute entscheidung
fällt noch einmal wir sind erwachsene
menschen und wir wollen den
bestmöglichen erfolg wir wollen nicht
deutschland der afg überlassen
wir wollen nicht dass deutschland von
den grünen regiert wird weil wir glauben
dass da überhaupt keine
regierungserfahrung besteht bei den
beiden kandidaten jedenfalls keine
ausreichende und deswegen haben wir den
klaren anspruch aber nach 16 jahren
union wird es schon noch mal eine
herkulesaufgabe sein zu zeigen dass wir
programmatisch lust auf die zukunft
haben dass wir ideen haben dass wir
sozusagen nicht nur diejenigen fragen
die seit 40 jahren politik machen das
professionelle werden aber also dass wir
wirklich mit neuen ideen für dieses land
aufwarten können
und auch was zu bieten haben und
programmatisch und personell aber
momentan unterschreiben das ist
geschlossen und entschlossen staber
momentane söder zerlegen sie sich
öffentlich der eine vorsitzende armin
laschet sagt wir müssen das schnell
entscheiden am besten heute wollte mit
ihnen telefonieren sie sagen
ende der woche das cdu-präsidium sagt
wir stehen geschlossen hinter armin
laschet sie haben gestern gesagt naja
wenn die cdu nicht hinter mir steht dann
mache ich es auch nicht also da ist doch
jetzt der offene machtkampf ausgebrochen
das wird aber von beobachtern anders
bewertet wenn wir uns anschauen wie
heute die medien lage ist und wie die
aktion kommentiert wird und auch was die
leute in den sozialen medien schreiben
sie sagen zum beispiel was ist da nur
los bei der union ja und sagen wir ich
weiß dass sie da nicht so dazu gehören
sie sind einer von den sensiblen und
rücksichtsvollen kommentatoren und
beobachtern
natürlich gibt es andere die bisschen
die scharfmacher sind die dann immer
gern was hinein stilisieren und dann
sagen ja auseinandersetzung ich habe
heute etwa eine sehr charmant gefunden
ich habe heute auf irgendeiner der
sendungen gesehen die grünen machen
große pressekonferenz und sagt jeder
muss man uns jetzt ausblenden habig weg
waren wir zu cdu schalten
am nachmittag war was ähnliches nehmen
wir müssen jetzt weg schalten wir müssen
zu ziehen also ich finde es schon wir
haben da jetzt schon eine menge also ich
mach der kinderzahl einem guten gespräch
und am ende immer da wo sie kommen mir
spaß oder so ein bisschen krimi martin
spaß spaß spaß ist eine kategorie die im
unterhaltungsteil der bild -zeitung mehr
als gerechtfertigt ist bei uns geht es
um verantwortung zur verantwortung hat
der bau eines stellen sie es geht um
unglaublich viel
das ist die wichtigste position
politische aufgabe die es in deutschland
gibt die eine enorme auswirkungen auf
europa hat und zwar auf ganz europa und
deswegen ist es auch nicht so dass wir
das jetzt in einigen sekunden und
stunden entscheiden muss sondern da muss
man wirklich überlegen und wegen was das
beste ist und dann entscheiden das
sicherlich und bis zur wahl sind nur
noch fünf monate zeit
und am ende soll uns keiner vorwerfen
wir hätten aus irgendeiner
drucksituation weil 23 kommentatoren
sagen jetzt müsst ihr entscheiden hätten
wir nicht richtig entschieden denn die
verantwortung die daraus folgt ist enorm
für die person die das ganze schulter
muss aber auch für die partei was sagen
sie denn denjenigen die in der union in
der cdu sagen sie werden zwar ein prima
kandidat aber kanzler
das trauen wir nicht so weil markus
söder ist ein opportunist sind sie ein
opportunist
nö und was sagen sie denjenigen die in
der cdu so etwas behaupten die sagen sie
könnten ein guter kandidat sein aber am
ende wäre es schwierig mit ihnen als
verlässlicher kanzler kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass das jemand sagt können
sich nicht vorstellen dass in der cdu
dass jemand behauptet nein kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen dann zum abschluss so
dass sie sagen ist möglicherweise in
dieser woche eine fraktionssitzung wenn
sie dann noch mal drauf schauen auf die
unionsfraktion und auf die stimmen die
sie hören
glauben sie dass sie in dieser fraktion
eine mehrheit hätten wenn es eine
abstimmung gebe spannende spekulationen
dürfen natürlich andere machen
ich finde ich finde wir gehen jetzt von
tag zu tag und schritt zu schritt und
denken vom ergebnis her wenn fraktionen
wenn parteibasis wenn die vorstände und
gremien ein einheitliches bild zeichnen
und wir müssen uns ja auch gegenseitig
unterstützen auch ein cdu kandidat muss
von der csu unterstützt werden
und deswegen muss man die nächsten tagen
ist er sorgsam miteinander umgehen wir
erhalten viel von armin laschet wir
können sowohl als kanzler als auch
kandidat vorstellen
wir glauben aber auch dass der
csu-vorsitzende ich sehr sehr gut kann
und wenn wir plötzlich glauben doch
eigentlich dass ich doch wieder zum
guten gegeben aber sie glauben doch und
ihr csu grüne minister oder mir die
aussage zu ich traue mir die aufgabe zu
aus der csu hört man sie werden auch
ältere herr bezogen sind sie der bessere
im vergleich zur branche das müssen
andere beurteilen das kann ich nicht
sagen herzlichen dank markus söder für
das interview in münchen und wir werden
weiter schauen was in münchen passiert
und was berlin passiert herzlichen dank
für die zeit
herzlichen dank auch